be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
so as we get into our discussion about
Batman zero year what we're going to
find here is that while Batman didn't
necessarily get a full continuity reboot
that is to say he didn't see the same
kind of reboot as characters like
Superman or the flash what we're going
to find is that for those of you guys
who we're interested in jumping into the
Batman series that Batman 0 year is
going to be a great place to start
because in truth the story of Batman and
his parents is really an ageless tale
and so what we're going to do as you
progressed through this story is that
were ultimately going to pick up with
Batman already being an adult and
arriving back in Gotham and ultimately
undertaking the mantle of Batman and so
what we do is we start here with a
secret city is that we find that we're
basically picking up with the Red Hood
gang and again this is a really cool tie
in with with Scott Snyder here in terms
of what he's using for the Red Hood gang
and the reason why is because as we'll
see as the story progresses Scott Snyder
is basically using a combination of the
original 1951 Red Hood but he's also
using I gather using this in conjunction
with the Alan Moore Red Hood and the
reason why I say that is because what we
find is that the Red Hood gang is of
course I guess involved in some kind of
a robbery but the Red Hood gang does not
identify themselves by name they simply
identify themselves by numbers the
leader of course being Red Hood one and
the others are referred to numerically
most presumably based on their rankings
that is to say where they stand in
relation to the respect among the other
gang members and the Red Hood one so Red
Hood too would most likely be the second
highest person up and someone as so
forth but again what happens here is
that as this Bank is being robbed the
bank manager seems to stand up to this
gang member he seems to stand up to the
Red Hood one and simply tell Red Hood
one that he really can't he can't do
this that he really can't get himself
involved in this capacity and so what we
find is that Red Hood
and structure ed hood 5 to kill this
bank manager and so red hood 5 simply
knocks the bank manager unconscious now
initially this is a go as far as to say
a shock to red hood 1 but what it does
is it puts him on alert and the reason
why is because his red hood one
describes to us red hood 5 murders
people without any real regard and so
the fact that he would actually knock
this bank manager unconscious as opposed
to just killing him is again really sort
of a I guess an alert to him really
something to indicate if things aren't
what they're supposed to be and so what
we find here is that as they're
basically interrogating him as red hood
one is beginning to put the pieces
together he realizes again this is not
red hood 5 and so what's revealed to us
is that as red hood 5 begins to battle
the the other members of the Red Hood
gang that we learned this is actually
Bruce Wayne and again this is basically
a reintroduction this is Bruce Wayne
picking up with becoming and I guess
returning to to Gotham as a vigilante
and so once Bruce Wayne is able to
attack or the very least thwart the Red
Hood gang he's ultimately able to escape
into the sewers in escape back home now
the difference here with the way this
story goes is that Bruce Wayne didn't
simply just arrive at Wayne Manor one
day and then immediately undertake the
mantle of Batman and start attacking
people instead Bruce Wayne is actually
living in the I guess the most
crime-ridden part of Gotham and this is
kind of interesting for a couple reasons
the first is because I would go as far
as to say that it gives Bruce Wayne a
really good understanding of what crime
is like of what it's like to live in
that part of the city but what it also
does is it basically puts him in the
lion's den he knows exactly where to go
and who it is that he needs to get to
but what's happening here is there's
also a mishmash of other things taking
place in Bruce Wayne's life one of the
most notable things is that Alfred
Pennyworth is really debating with Bruce
Wayne for one Alfred Pennyworth doesn't
like the idea of living in this
brownstone I guess this the sort of read
and and British kind of apartment which
is what they're actually called
brownstone apartments but it doesn't
like living in the heart of Gotham
around these crime ridden areas but more
so than that what do you really wants to
see Bruce Wayne do is step into the role
that had been left vacant by Thomas
Wayne but Bruce Wayne is really I guess
doesn't want to get involved in this you
really doesn't want to join this concept
and this again gives us some very
valuable insight into the mine
set of Bruce Wayne because what is it
what it tells us here is that Bruce
Wayne doesn't care about the material
things he doesn't really care about
being against a major part of Gotham
which is ironic because as well find in
later comics especially when we get into
the court of owls and the night of owls
Bruce Wayne is most effective in being
able to change Gotham when he's fighting
the war on two fronts one when he's able
to contribute financially to the city of
Gotham to revamp the areas that need to
be revamped but also when he's carrying
out his vigilante role as Batman but
again as the two of them begin to talk
and as a two of them begin to continue
this is when we really see Scott Snyder
drawing on the various incarnations of
the Red Hood when he tells us that the
way the Red Hood is able to boast of
their ranks is through a combination of
blackmail and threatening now again this
really seems to draw more elements from
Alan Moore's Red Hood than it does the
original 1951 Red Hood and the reason I
say that is because during The Killing
Joke when Alan Moore was effectively
giving us the origins of the Joker the
way he had done it was basically telling
us that a Joker I guess the person who
would become the Joker was shanghaied
into it that criminals were going around
with a Red Hood and they were I guess
approaching people who had some kind of
inside knowledge about the place the
criminals intended to rob and what they
would tell these people is that they
were going to be the inside man that the
hood was going to be a way to protect
their identities but in reality the hood
was designed to basically depict them as
the leader of the Red Hood gang and so
if for some reason they were caught by
the police or they were seen by the
police the criminals could point to the
Red Hood and say that he's the leader
he's the one that orchestrated the whole
thing and they could simply escape
leaving the person who was basically
tricked into the situation to be left at
the behest of the authorities and so
again what happens here is we learn a
lot more about this entire content a lot
more about what's going on with with
Bruce Wayne again tying to this idea
that he has a mishmash of things going
on one of the things that happens here
is that he meets Jim Gordon for the
first time as he's operating under this
vigilante attitude and of course Jim
Gordon makes his stance known on the
stance of the Gotham police department
and no uncertain terms when he says that
of course they know about this vigilante
who is going around and trying to stop
criminals but that ultimately the rule
of stopping criminals in the city of
Gotham lies with the police and the
problem here is that if one man is able
to do what he wants and/or
to try to curb crime and because it
makes him a vigilante other people may
take up the cause and would lead to a
state of lawlessness and in truth this
is a very reasonable argument here this
is a very valuable argument because if
everybody were to carry out their own
manner of justice and there would be no
true justice justice would be left to
the perspective of the person who was
carrying it out and so while one man
would say that a person who steals from
him should maybe and be imposed with
some kind of a some kind of jail time
another person may say that if a person
steals from him they should die and so
there's no real standard for justice
within the city and so this is one of
the reasons why Jim Gordon seems to be
so avidly against the vigilante now
again Jim Gordon doesn't really tell us
this per se we're just kind of left to
interpret this we're kind of left to
believe that this is most likely the
case which I'll go as far as to say that
that would that most likely seems to be
what's going on but again we see that
over time as we get through this first
secret City event that Bruce Wayne is
basically continuing his attempts to
stop the Red Hood gang and in one of the
most notable instances he actually
undertakes the disguise of Oswald
Cobblepot and what this tells us is that
Oswalt Cobblepot has basically in
existence at this point in time
he's already operating as perhaps some
kind of criminal element but again what
happens here is the Red Hood gang
realizes that this is not as Walt
Cobblepot that in fact it is Bruce Wayne
and so while they don't know that it's
really Bruce Wayne by name with a dino
is that it's the vigilante and so what
happens here is of course Bruce Wayne is
able to escape one more time and I guess
grab Oswald Cobblepot who's currently
tied up in the the bottom of this of
this blimp and then ultimately get the
two of them away but in addition to this
I guess this complex series of events
that are really making things difficult
for Bruce Wayne in terms of being a
vigilante
we also continue on with this path of
him as the man Bruce Wayne that is to
say the fact that he's trying to remain
hidden from the public eye because again
at this point in time Bruce Wayne was
declared dead by his uncle Phillip Kane
and in fact his uncle Phillip came to
tells him this when he takes him to to
Wayne tower and again tries to basically
do the same thing that that Alfred
Pennyworth had done where he tries to
get him to step into the role of Thomas
Wayne as the leader I guess the head of
Wayne Enterprises but again Bruce Wayne
really kind of shuns this but all this
really comes to a head when Alfred Kane
exposes Bruce Wayne to the press
ultimately leading to Gotham realizing
that Bruce Wayne is in fact alive and
what this does is it really kind of
backs Bruce Wayne into a corner if Bruce
Wayne were to simply say or I guess see
were to acquiesce publicly and say that
he has no intention of taking up the
mantle or I guess stepping into the role
of heading up Wayne Enterprises then you
would destroy the morale and I guess the
perception of Wayne Enterprises and it
could even go as far as to cause the
company to go bankrupt do the fact that
shareholders are most likely to bail out
in the sense that if the I guess the the
heir to the company won't even have
anything to do with it then why should
they keep investing in it and so at the
same time we see that eventually I guess
Phillip Kane meets with Edward nygma who
again at this point isn't really playing
the role of the Riddler but it's still a
relatively sinister person the reason
why I say that is because what Phillip
Kane does is basically speaks with a
Riddler in saying that what's taking
place in Gotham right now is a power
struggle between the Kane's who were
previously in charge of ACE chemical
which was bought out by Gotham or I
guess by the by Wayne Industries but we
also see that Wayne Industries is trying
to maintain its power hold on on Gotham
City itself that is to say the company
is trying to to maintain its stature and
so what Edward nygma says is the only
real way for Phillip Kane to fix this
problem is to kill Bruce Wayne and what
I would do is ultimately generate
sympathy for Bruce Wayne or for the
fairway enterprises which in turn would
turn public opinion and they're on their
side of course Phillip Caine turns out
turns on this idea and so what Edward
nygma does is he goes about his own
accord
and he hires the red gang the Red Hood
gang to kill Bruce Wayne instead and so
against Bruce Wayne is trying to stop
the Red Hood gang what we see is that
all these pieces sort of begin to come
together at the very end when we see
that Bruce Wayne meets up with the Red
Hood gang and the Red Hood gang
realizing who he is confront him in his
home and almost beat him to death now
ultimately the leader of the Red Hood
gang shoots Bruce Wayne and leaves them
for dead but of course Bruce Wayne is
able to get back to Wayne Manor and
Alfred is able to tend to him but again
this really just kind of covers the
events in secret city this really gives
us the ideas of what it is it ultimately
leads to Bruce Wayne as he begins to
undertake the role of a
Batman then what we'll find here in the
second section in Dark City is that he
ultimately takes over this mantle he
ultimately becomes Batman with regards
to his stance in Gotham City so with
Dark City what we do here is we pick up
right where we left off with a secret
city in a sense that with Bruce Wayne
having escaped the presumed death at the
hands of the Red Hood that he's being
tended to by Alfred of course Alfred is
doing what he can to make sure that
Bruce Wayne's wounds are taken care of
where they need to so of course he
doesn't contract any kind of an
infection here but what happens is that
after Bruce Wayne has finished being
tended to by Alfred he begins to go and
inspect the grounds of Wayne Manor and
what he does is he stumbles across a
hole that he had previously fallen in as
a child in which of course he had been
rescued by his dad but what he does is
we he basically gives us a very touching
moment here and this is what I really
enjoy about Scott Snyder's Batman
because in previous versions of Batman
we didn't see very many of these moments
these moments were really isolated to
him maybe recollecting various memories
about his parents and to a degree it's
the same here but what he does is he
begins to speak with his father
metaphorically of course speaking to the
spirit of his father or the memory of
his father in saying that he feels like
he's failed in his role to protect
Gotham and his attempt to come back and
to restore Gotham back to the way it was
before
and so what he does is he begins
pondering these things is what he
decides the best way for him to carry
out this mission is to simply not do it
as a man because as a man again it could
be perceived that he's somebody who
could be killed off and so what he does
is he adopts the mantle of Batman here
and so what we do is we switch to the
Red Hood gang as they're unloading some
chemicals from a warehouse that they're
presumably robbing here and what happens
is that the person on the inside of the
plant is of course continuing to load
chemicals out but as we realize no one's
actually picking them up and when he
comes out to realize or I guess to find
out where everybody's at what we see is
that the care the members of the Red
Hood gang who were previously taking
these chemicals from him and loading
them into the vehicles have been strung
up on a sign and the shape of a bat and
so what we find is a Batman pursues this
last member of the Red Hood
and then strings him up presumably
leaving him for the police and so what
we do is we jump back to the Batcave
here and again in Bruce Wayne and Alfred
are continuing to go over everything
they found so far they're contending me
to go over the investigation and what's
really interesting about this is that
this is when we really see the character
of Batman beginning to take shape
so we really begin to see him see him
form what we had seen with secret city
was that Bruce Wayne was operating as a
blunt instrument he was basically a
broadsword swatting away at the criminal
element of Gotham
but as Batman he's more from a precision
scalpel I guess he's able to carve away
at the places that need to be carved at
so they can ultimately form this grander
picture here and this is how all this is
beginning to take form this is how all
this is beginning to grow of course we
see that Bruce Wayne and Alfred are
discussing the intended plans of the Red
Hood gang and what they come to the
realization of is that they're not
arbitrarily taking things that they've
been taking chemicals from plants that
are owned by Wayne Manor or I'm sorry
Wayne Industries more specifically what
the intention seems to be here is that
they're most likely going to I guess
gather these chemicals together and
detonate them in a kind of bomb of sorts
and so what Bruce Wayne does is he goes
to the press and he basically has the
press gather outside of ace chemical and
he tells the press that what he's
realized is that the intention of the
Red Hood gang here is to effectively
detonate this bomb and I guess tomorrow
where as far as it would be the next day
and so what happens is that while
Commissioner Gordon is watching these
entire events unfold he ultimately heads
to ace Chemical along with the police
and most likely a SWAT team and they
begin the process of trying to take out
the Red Hood gang and so what happens as
Bruce Wayne takes the takes this time
while he's speaking to enter the ACE
chemical plant and the reason why this
happens is because due to his discussion
due to his talking here and I guess is
announcing the plans of the Red Hood
gang the Red Hood gang attacks Bruce
Wayne along with the with the press what
they actually do here is they shoot
rockets down on everybody and again what
this really tells us is that there
doesn't really seem to be a whole lot of
concern on behalf of the Red Hood gang
in terms of anybody becoming aware of
their plans in the sense that willingly
firing missiles towards the press would
obviously indicate that they're real
is no concern here because as far as as
far as we can tell the intention of the
Red Hood gang is that they're probably
going to detonate this bomb and then
they don't care what happens next their
goal is to simply just promote chaos
here and so what happens is that when
Batman actually enters ace chemicals
that he's confronted by the Red Hood and
so when the Red Hood is prepared to
actually kill Batman proper what happens
is the lights go out inside of the plant
and so what happens as Bruce Wayne dons
his Batman costume and begins going
about the process of confronting and
subduing these various members of the
Red Hood gang ultimately leading him to
confronting Red Hood one and this is
when Scott Snyder again really points to
the Alan Moore story of The Killing Joke
as the origin or the the one defining
continuity of the Joker because what
happens here is that wala while the Red
Hood and while Batman are fighting one
another that ultimately the Red Hood
falls into a giant vat of chemicals
which is the same thing that we had seen
with regards to either Killing Joke when
we had seen that he had fallen into the
chemicals under a different set of
circumstances but the fact remains that
he fell into these chemicals which would
ultimately go on to allow him to become
the Joker the other reason why we know
this to be the case is because this is
where Scott Snyder ends the entire story
of the Red Hood gang you simply stops
here and so what he's basically telling
us here is that we know how this story
plays out we know how things go from
here and so from here what this does is
effectively lead into Batman becoming a
major element of Gotham City this leads
into Batman becoming the superhero for
Gotham City that is to say Gotham City's
protector and what we'll see of course
I'll post a reading list on the bottom
is that while this story comes after the
events of nine of hours and quarter
valves that and more or less following
the chronological order of things this
will ultimately lead into those stories
this will lead into the Justice League
this will lead into the night of owls
and Court of owls and so on and so forth
but again this is really just kind of
giving us the introduction to how it is
that Batman caming to is it came into
existence with regards to the new 52
with that being said I'm gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later